you
your surgeon may perform laparoscopic
lysis of adhesions or laparoscopic
adhesion OSIS to remove scar tissue from
the organs in your abdomen
normally the surfaces of your abdominal
organs are slippery and move easily past
one another as you go about your daily
activities
if you have bands of scar tissue in your
abdomen called adhesions your abdominal
organs stick to each other or to the
abdominal wall these adhesions can cause
bowel obstruction by constricting your
intestines or twisting or pulling them
out of place partially or completely
blocking food or stool from moving
through them if you are a woman
adhesions can also cause infertility by
twisting or pulling your fallopian tubes
out of place partially or completely
blocking fertilized eggs from reaching
your uterus or a baby can grow and
develop
the most common cause of abdominal
adhesions is abdominal surgery other
causes can be abdominal infections such
as peritonitis inflammatory conditions
such as appendicitis abdominal trauma or
radiation
to begin your surgeon will inject gas
into your abdomen to expand the
abdominal cavity making it easier to see
the structures inside then your surgeon
will make a small incision to access the
inside of your abdomen
he or she will insert a laparoscope
which contains a light a camera and a
magnifying device the laparoscope will
project images on to a monitor to guide
your surgeons work
after examining the abdominal cavity
your surgeon will make three or four
small incisions in your abdomen through
which to pass surgical instruments using
these instruments your surgeon will cut
the adhesions to free the organs from
each other once all of the adhesions are
divided your surgeon will remove the
laparoscopic instruments the incisions
will be closed with sutures
followed by skin glue or skin closure
tape
if there are complications with your
laparoscopic procedure your surgeon will
switch to an open procedure with a
larger incision